robin asking oh asking the other day
would gm title likely increase your
income
uh it would probably decrease my income
because i would have to spend so much
time
away from
like streaming and youtube content to
focus on getting better
okay i'm playing wayne jones
i think wayne plays g6 and then
eventually d5
i played gawain a while ago
[Music]
i played gawain in uh this man feingold
like mayhem tournament
same opening as a previous game
go eric rosen playing in london against
a british person
i don't know
uh i think 95 is the main move these
lines get really tricky though
there's a trap c5 takes
queen a5 queen d2 takes in the knight a4
which
is like a pseudo queen trap
if you were able to learn one language
in a matter of seconds which one would
you choose
oh
um
i want to say toki pona
created by sonia lang but that that
would like realistically it would take
ooh
grandmaster falling for opening prep
that would probably take uh
just a couple days to learn
so probably like chinese or icelandic
which could take like a whole lifetime
to learn
yeah this is one of the few traps i know
in this uh
this line with like 95 c5
the problem for black is all these
squares are pretty much covered
and i there's queen d6 but then i take
and i win stuff
i'm pretty sure uh who was it magnus
trapped nereditsky with like a very
similar trap
in a very similar line
[Music]
wait you can trap it
oh
uh there's also knight f7 but i think
knight g6 is the way to go
oh wait in queen c6
or queen d7 knight c5
i think it's okay
if queen c6 i fork
if that i take
oh it gets weird
um
i think it's okay though
[Music]
queen e6 i think knight c5
there's queen b6
i got focus here
queen b6
i have 97 that line
up two pawns here
and queen b6 is forced
if you're here
here here i fork
that move i forgot about
yeah the problem is if i take the rook
queen eggs bishop in my night strapped
so i could
take the knight
also take the other knight
we have queen d5 now
taking way too much time but
um
i'm winning all the pawns
thank you kind person
smallzyk
i appreciate the gifted subs
yeah we move faster
yeah the light wants to reroute to g5
the queen might end up going to g5
bishop e6
and this move now
i just want to simplify
take the bishop with check i'm hitting
the queen
jack
fancy
up three pawns
i mean probably g3 solidify
no rush to
to win probably this is this
always enjoy your streams smile
oh that makes me smile
if i get the pawn e5 then pawns are
nicely placed
welcome to iwan
[Music]
half a year of joy
hey thank you sausage
probably c3 is coming soon
56 ideas
i think it still works right now
and bishop d3
be sometimes hard like psychologically
to win
i know i'm playing a decent player but i
have so many pawns
okay
got the job done